The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So I'll be sitting
down here and showing you
a whole lot of really
cool videos on YouTube,
and battlecode players that
I have programmed especially
for tonight.
So here we go.
What's the point here?
The point here is to talk
about the things that
have been done before in swarm,
and thinking about swarm.
So let's go straight
to a YouTube video
and look at this animation.
So you can see here, there
will be these birds that
are following the green blob,
and they avoid the red blob.
And what they're trying to do is
match one another's direction,
try to get a certain distance
from the other birds,
and try to avoid obstacles.
And so you can see
how the combination
of a few simple rules can
create a behavior that's
sort of complicated looking,
or a behavior that's
somewhat fluid.
Whereas if you
had manually tried
to get them all to go
in the same direction,
it might have looked
somewhat more rigid.
And it might not have
been able to handle things
like obstacles.
So let's look at another video
of how this is done in nature.
Now, this is a massive
number of birds.
I think in the video description
it says this is 300,000 birds.
Wow.
And it's so pretty how it
undulates and smushes around.
Here's another view
of the same thing.
I think they'll all take
off in the distance.
Look at how pretty that is.
And the all sort of do it
once, but there's certainly
nobody in control.
What a pretty-- ah, you've got
to love pictures of nature,
in the evening,
in a lecture hall.
We're about as far from
nature as people can get.
My goodness.
Ah, that's so pleasing.
When are they going
to show the birds?
I'm referring to the birds
that aren't in the water.
The birds in the air, yeah.
So what we want to
do today is just
talk about the things
that are recognized
as elements of swarm behavior.
And then we'll
show how our robots
can do much better than the
enemy robots if we do it right.
Look at this.
It's almost like two separate
swarms in certain areas.
And it's an interesting
problem to say, at what point
is it possible to
split into two swarms?
Because maybe one of them
got too far from the other,
or maybe it's just
too gosh darn big.
Or maybe one half of them
are Democrats, the other half
Republicans.
There are a lot of
reasons that they
might want to split into parts.
So we'll talk about that too.
Next, we'll talk about crowds.
I mean, this is a thing
that you deal with every day
when you go to eat
battlecode lecture dinner.
You come up here, and there's
people trying to get to food.
And I guess the food is there.
No, this is a bad example,
because these guys are just
going to walk
through one another.
And the goal is trying
to get them to anticipate
who isn't going to be in
the way, and to form lanes.
That was the problem that these
guys were trying to address.
And I guess nowadays
it's becoming
popular to post your
thesis material online
and to animate it in 3D.
I don't see why this
is animated in 3D.
You could just
show the same thing
with a two dimensional map.
Now here you're going
to see ripples form.
And that's the expectation path.
And so a small perturbation
in the position of someone
is amplified into
like avoid this lane.
And here he shows it
again with some lines.
He does it with more people,
because every computer
scientist knows that more
is better, especially
when it comes to simulations.
And so he shows a bunch of
them, and how these guys
are going up, those guys
are going down there.
And they sort of
make this vortex.
And I think-- oh, yeah.
I remember.
This is really silly.
The end of this
video, you're not
going to see it coming at all.
You're thinking, all right,
where can he go from here?
He can show-- so
there's their model,
and there's some
alternative models
showing that their model is
a lot better because people
aren't bunching up.
So there's these high ES low
and high distance models.
Which basically, the guys are
just avoiding one another.
But in their model, they're
sort of creating a density
field for an expected position.
I think this is supposed
to be simulating armies.
I guess they want a job
at Pixar or whatever.
And so they just sort
of put this one in here,
like oh, look at how
realistic your armies will
look if people at the back
move 10 times as fast.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And then
another army is over here.
Because just like I said,
these computer science people
like nothing more than
to have a lot of things.
I once saw a simulation.
Oh, this was crazy.
It was a simulation
of neutronics.
So this is like
a college campus.
I mean, you could really tell
where this guy's coming from.
Movies, campus.
And it's like people are
coming from certain doors
and going to others.
And I think the next shot he'll
show the paths of these people,
showing that they're not bumping
into each other that much,
and that they're kind
of straightish paths.
Which is supposed to
be very impressive.
But back to my
other story, I was
watching a neutronics
simulation.
And it had like 2
billion particles in it
that were all in a lattice.
OK, I'm going to pause this
here when it gets to the city.
I mean, my goodness.
How more complete do you need?
Once you've seen it,
you've kind of seen it.
But anyway, this 2 billion
particle lattice, which took
like 10 hours on a
giant supercomputer
to do this simulation of
damage from radiation,
from like high energy
particle radiation.
And the final result of this
massive simulation that I saw,
it was to show that this
one incoming particle had
ricocheted in a couple of ways.
And the diagram of
this final result
from this giant
computation, which
was like the very end
of his presentation,
because for some
reason people don't
like to show the graphics first.
They like to tell you
all the words first.
In any case, he
showed me this thing.
And it's like a little
hook or something.
It was really stupid looking.
Oh, my goodness.
Can't believe it.
But no, this guy's
final result is
going to be much more exciting.
So he's got these
people, and he's
like, well, this
isn't realistic.
In a real city, there are cars.
So you've got to only
walk on the crosswalks.
And you've got to
avoid certain things.
Maybe you form lanes of traffic
on these crosswalks kind
of automatically.
Oh, now he's getting more.
He's like, OK, I've got
too much time on my hands.
I better implement stop lights.
But it's still not
that realistic,
because what if people
get hit by cars?
There are no cars to
hit people, or to almost
hit them, or to
scare them and get
them to jump out of the way.
So now we've got a 3D flyover,
because the only thing
cooler than having
a 3D environment
is a slow pan and zoom.
So that's what he's
sort of doing here.
And he puts the cars in.
Obviously, he has
excellent taste.
All the cars are from 1970.
And I guess there's jaywalking.
Oh, right.
This is like a chemical
evacuation or something,
so all these people are
covered in yellow stuff.
And they're running away.
And that's supposed to be really
useful for planning evacuations
and such.
Yeah.
And everybody else
is just like, OK,
I'm going to worry about
that three, two, one, now.
And then the other people
start running away, too.
They have really
bad reaction time.
And then this is like, people
are walking in the street,
and how it's messing up traffic.
And it's like, wow,
this traffic is
almost as bad as New
York City traffic.
Almost as bad.
And then, I mean,
what else can this guy
do after he's done
this many things?
Well, the last thing
that he has is aliens.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So there you go.
Just to show that
everybody likes
to have a little bit of fun
with pathing and navigation.
So let's talk a little
bit about the things
that we saw in those videos.
and how they apply
to battlecode.
So there's a whole
question of centralized
versus decentralized control.
And in the ones that we saw,
they weren't centralized.
So I'm going to
show you examples
in battlecode of both of those.
Now, those can have
impacts on whether there's
a radio attack possible,
whether your strategy's going
to be vulnerable to that.
Whether it's like a
map dependent strategy,
because maybe on a
centralized controller,
it works really well
if it's a tiny map.
But maybe if it's
a huge map, you've
got to start having multiple
swarms that are independent.
And talking about
distributing information
is another thing
to worry about it.
So let's consider that
in the boyds model, which
is supposed to sound like birds
if you have a Brooklyn accent,
they considered several aspects
for computing the next position
for each actor in the swarm.
The separation of each
one to its neighbors.
The pushing together of each
one, which they call cohesion,
because the smarter
you sound, the more
Ph.D. Money and grant
money you can make.
They talk about alignment
so that everybody's
facing the same direction.
Now, that's somewhat
different this year
than it has been in
past battlecode years.
And then I guess they don't
talk too much about it,
but they considered the later
effects of group splitting
and lane creation,
which we saw today.
So let's see here.
I showed some examples
of these things.
Alignment this year
is worth noting
that there used to be a method
where you could take the robot
info and do dot direction.
You could get the direction
of any robot that you can see.
Now, in this year's battlecode,
there's no direction.
So what are you going to do?
So let's see here.
You can get the distances
for separation and cohesion.
I mean, these are
just a fancy way
of just saying there's
like a spring between you
and the others.
And this one is just saying that
you're headed the right way.
There's really almost
nothing complicated to it.
And we're going to end up
seeing some pretty neat looking
behavior from very simple rules.
So yeah, let's talk
about how you're
going to know that you're
facing the right direction.
I mean, you could check
all the neighbors.
Let's see here, face
the right direction.
You could check
all the neighbors
against all the other ones.
So you'd be checking
to see if robot
ID number 97 was from this
position, and then that one.
And then you would try
to find where he was,
and correlate that,
and get the direction.
And then take an average for
all the robots that you can see.
That would be really
computationally expensive.
Another option is
to say, all right,
take average of
all allied robots.
Or all within a range.
And then see how
that average moves.
So that's like an
implicit direction
for the group of allied robots.
And then an individual
robot, by doing that,
could see where all of them are.
Another option is just
to radio broadcast
so that somebody somewhere is
deciding what direction to go.
Or maybe all of them vote on the
direction that they want to go,
because maybe some of
them are close to enemies
and other ones are
standing on mines.
And maybe they want
to put it up to a vote
so that they can
wait for 50 turns
before finding out
which direction they're
going to go, and end up going
in the wrong direction anyway.
Or they could have a
recount, and anything.
It could be really fun.
You could do like a whole
political simulation.
So here are some
considerations when
you're talking about central
control versus the group mind.
Where the central controller,
you'd need a leader.
And so leaders have
to have elections,
and they also can die, and
sometimes they get lost.
So those are things to worry
about when you have a leader.
That means that the
headquarters is a good choice.
And so if you can do all of
your computations in one place,
that's much more efficient.
Imagine if you had
to-- every robot
has all the same information.
But if all of them
make the decisions,
then they all have to
do a lot of thinking.
And in this game, if you
use up 10,000 byte codes,
each of those robots is going
to have twice the power upkeep.
It's going to be
pretty significant.
So you could have the leader
broadcast all kinds of things.
And later on we're going to talk
about some more little details
of what the leader can broadcast
besides just what direction
you're going in that can really
save you a lot of trouble.
If you have a group mind,
it's a little different.
You can have a
better site range,
which is to say that
in previous years
you were limited to just
one robot site range.
So having a group
mind sort of gave you
more access to the
edges of your cloud.
And you could also make
it so that the front guys
are leading.
Which would be really
useful so that you
could have them be the
first ones to note.
This year it's not so important.
But in like a real flock
of birds or something
you might develop after
this, it would be.
You can also broadcast of the
enemy locations in a group
mind.
There's no reason why a group
mind can't use broadcast.
It's just a question of whether
you expect to receive something
from a single entity,
or whether you
expect to integrate
a bunch of broadcasts
from a lot of entities.
Broadcasting is becoming
cheaper and cheaper
now that the read cost has
been decreased from the 0.01
to 0.003.
We've also increased
the number of channels
in the latest release so
that your broadcasts are
more secure against
radio attacks.
At least those spanning attacks.
It is worth mentioning
that you should
be moving your channel somehow.
Come up with your own algorithm
for shifting the channel
that you're using.
Something, for example, that
uses the clock round number
so that you could always be
looking in a different place,
and the enemy won't
locate which channels
you're using on the radio.
Which is to say,
which frequencies.
So you might also want
some other features.
So these boyds things with
their separation and such.
What other features do you
want that aren't in boyds?
So you might want
some in and out motion
so that everybody takes a
uniform amount of damage.
You might want some
cycling behavior.
You might want to heal the weak
by going back to the med bays.
You might want to apply
shields at shield generators.
Those are encampments
that you could build.
And you might want to make
sure that each robot knows
the size of the pack.
And if each one only has so
much information, especially
about the enemy, then they
need to be able to get around.
I mean, this year it's not
so much of a problem again.
So let's see here.
There's sort of an
interesting trade
off here when you think
about the density of a group.
But we're doing too much
talking and not enough watching.
Let's watch an example.
So I have some players here.
And swarm one, I'm just going
to pick any old map here.
Let's go to chunky.
Chunky is a map I made which has
just these big chunks of mines.
So here you can see, I've
got my swarm one player.
It's very simple.
It's quite close to the other
players that I showed you.
It's not that exciting,
because the robots are just
sort of-- they rush
at one another.
They come together
in the middle.
They go toward one another.
There's not that much
swarm-like behavior.
And when they come
together, they're
not really doing anything
that intelligent.
Like at this
moment, neither side
is really being that smart
about what to do with the other.
Here I'm going to do it
slightly differently.
I'm going to have the robots,
instead of just choosing
a rally point at random at the
very beginning of the game,
and having each robot
compute it individually, here
in swarm one, I'm
going to show how
in swarm two,
which is this code,
we've included the ability
for the headquarters
to tell the robots where to go.
So you could see--
let's see here,
let's change the
font size so that you
can see what I'm saying and
follow along in the code.
Font 16, OK.
The headquarter code here is
what the headquarters is doing.
So it does some
spawning soldiers.
And I've got a nice
code documentation here.
And it moves the
rally point from time
to time, which is to say that
at round greater than 500,
it just sets the rally point to
the enemy headquarter location.
And it messages allies
about where to go.
So first it gets the
channel from my function
called getChannel.
And when I do that, I
say that if I'm team b,
I'm going to have
this multiplier.
If I'm team a, I'm going
to have this multiplier.
So that when I
calculate the channel,
I do the clock round number
times the multiplier,
modulo the game constants,
broadcast max channels.
So that means that the channel
that I'm broadcasting on
is continually rotating,
but because it's just
based on my team and the
clock round number, that
means that every robot can
still read off that channel.
Still knows where to
look for that channel.
And rotating frequencies is
actually a common practice
in modern military
communications.
After all, it might not
have occurred to you
that in the modern military,
they don't just flip open
their cell phones and then
say, hey General Saxony,
do you want to sort
of attack tonight?
And the general
goes, yeah, maybe.
I might.
I'm not sure.
Maybe I'll send you an email.
They often use
radio, because it's
there's not internet
connection out there
in the middle of nowhere.
And they have these
rotating radio frequencies.
So yeah, that's a good
thing that you'll have.
So once you've got the channel,
you need to have a message.
So here I've written
the message builder
that converts a map
location to an integer.
So you can see
that function here.
All I do is I multiply
the x value by 1,000
and I add the y value.
So then both x and y
values are included.
Finally, on that
unpacking side, I
use this function to
turn the integer back
into a map location.
It makes life easier.
So then at the robot side,
you can see the result.
So we're going to show
swarm one versus swarm two.
Swarm two has two advantages.
So here swarm two is in blue.
And swarm two has two
advantages, the first of which
is that it receives the
messages from the headquarters.
So it'll go attack at
round 500, rather than
the round that these guys are
attacking, which is round 200.
So I guess it has sort
of an advantage there.
And second advantage is, it
doesn't defuse mines in combat.
Some of you may be
familiar with World
of Warcraft or those type games.
Defusing mines in combat
is like looting in combat.
It's definitely a no-no.
You don't want to-- that's
not how to be a team player.
You could see the result is
that just because you aren't
defusing mines in combat
where the other team was,
you end up with almost
your whole army remaining.
What a huge difference.
And then quickly
at round 500, you
can see that these guys are
successfully receiving a goal.
And here in size
0.001 font, you can
see that it knows
its current location.
And it has a goal
location which has
been broadcast from this guy.
So there you can see
a little example,
but that's not as
exciting as it might be.
Let's consider adding
some distance tolerance
in go to location.
So let's do that so that
when they go to a location,
they don't just keep
bobbling around in there.
So that they can actually
start to get work done.
So here, they're
going to location.
And then they just calm down.
And they take their
spot, and they sit there.
Really nice.
And if they're on
a certain tile,
I even have they lay a mine.
So this is a neato
thing that I thought
of is if you lay mines not
in a fully dense pattern,
then when the enemy attacks,
you have the opportunity
to sort of whittle them down.
Because you might
have this situation.
It's kind of hard
to see on this map.
I might take a screenshot
and then work on it.
So let's say that we've
got these mines here,
and that we intend to use
them in a really clever way.
Yeah.
So let's go here.
Super leet.
So maybe the enemy
is coming this way.
Now, if they come
here, they can either
start to defuse the
mines, and they'll
be just waiting on that corner,
or they can infiltrate inside.
Because it doesn't really
present a giant obstacle
to them.
And once they're
in here, I'm going
to have a big advantage
because I can confront them
with a lot more area.
Because they're all
so sparsely laid out.
So I think this will
work really well.
And if they want
to retreat, there's
definitely no way that's
going to work for them.
Because they can't do any real
cycling in this configuration.
I think it's going to
totally mess them up.
So here in this one, I've got
these guys who are cleverly
not-- they're not going
to defuse mines in combat.
And they'll even sort of back
up and fight over the mines.
So here they're backing
up to the mines.
And they're trying to bring
the fight back to home.
Let's show it with swarm
one versus swarm three,
because then they won't
both have that part.
Oh, wait.
That was pretty one-sided.
Right.
So this is something
that happens.
So here the enemy
is going to show up
and I'm going to retreat
off the minefield.
So then they're sort of
busy, and I come back.
And then I retreat
a little bit more.
And they sort of start
defusing and they
think that's a good idea.
And then I sort of go this
back and forth type motion.
And that kind of thing
can help to string out
the enemies in a line.
Give me a little advantage.
But even still, it's not
looking that much like swarming.
Now, I want to make the point
that a lot of these maps
are absolutely filled
with these neutral mines,
especially to begin with.
In this map.
there's so many neutral
mines to get through.
If you were really intelligent,
you could take this path.
And I'll show an
example later of how
you could write a player
that really efficiently paths
through this space for
a whole mess of troops.
So here I'm retreating
past my little minefield.
And then I'm sort of
bopping on forward again.
And he's sort of
poking the dragon here.
He's making me irritated.
And so then-- oh, I'm
just going to kill him.
Hmm.
But the killing him was less
effective than it might have
been because a lot of my
guys got stuck back there.
And they didn't know what
to do because I told them,
please don't defuse
mines in combat.
And it was like
combat because they
were going to attack
the enemy headquarters.
But nevertheless,
these guys got stuck.
So what am I going to do?
Well, here's an
alternative where
you could say each guy has a
certain amount of patience.
And if he's stuck in
one spot, then he's
going to go ahead and defuse
those mines in combat.
So here, once again, this
pulling back and going forward
strategy is very effective
against an equally sized enemy.
These minefields are a
wonderful defensive advantage
that you should definitely use.
So then here, when
these guys get annoyed,
they can start digging through.
And eventually, they'll make
it through to the other side.
Which will be pretty
useful in that case.
Let's do another example
versus basic player.
I think this example
demonstrates that tunneling
effect a little bit better.
Now, basic player is building
all kinds of useful things,
like suppliers and generators.
And that's going to make
him especially powerful.
So it's going to be--
no, actually, I beat him.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: So that's
a really good example.
Let's move on, and I'm going
to try to beat swarm four.
So swarm four was
like-- well, maybe
I'll continue beating swarm one.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to use guided swarm, which
is a new player that I made.
So this guided
swarm's really neat.
This is a lot more like birds.
And the guided swarm's goal, his
goal is to be a little bit more
puffy.
Yeah, that's him up there.
Look at him.
He's like all cloud like.
And he's keeping it real.
What a guy.
So you can see here that the
guided swarm's kind of OK,
but he's so spread out that
he doesn't do well in combat.
What can we do to make
this guided swarm better?
What can we do-- I think one
thing that works really well
is to put him on a map
that's better for him.
So I'm going to put
him on this one.
Now he's a bit farther
away from the enemy.
And my hope is that
he'll have time
to produce enough
units that he'll
start laying a big minefield.
Yes, I think that will
help him out significantly.
Oh, come on.
Please lay that minefield.
Oh, he didn't have time
to lay the minefield.
I think what I'll do is
I'll tell him to build
the minefield just a
little bit earlier.
I'm going to make
this-- right now
I've got it-- ooh, don't let
me change the wrong code.
It's so easy to do that.
You think robot player got Java
is the code you're working on,
and it is, but you're wrong.
[LAUGHTER]
So I was working on
guided swarm one,
and I want the headquarters code
to start building these robots.
Oh, yeah.
I want him to research pickaxe.
And once he's
researched pickaxe,
I told him to tell the other
guys on channel plus 1.
So here you can use your
get channel function
and then add one,
and now you've got
sort of a set of
channels you can use.
So I want him to tell the others
to please start laying mines
as soon as I have
the pickaxe upgrade.
All right.
So that's going to happen.
I'll just make it at this
point, and hopefully that
will give him enough
time to do it.
Yeah.
So now he's going to
build fewer allied units
before he starts researching.
Gosh, this is a tiny map.
If you can see this accurately,
you don't need glasses.
Yes, that's probably true.
Ah, right.
So they started laying mines.
And look at that pattern.
Look at the pattern they used.
Oh, my goodness.
They must be somewhat skilled.
Can't believe that.
Ah, ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: But
you see the point.
The point that I made was
that I found a really neat way
to make them lay mines
in the right pattern.
Now, maybe you can't
really see that well.
So I'm going to open up
good fashioned Mathematica.
Not that.
Good old fashioned-- not that.
Good old fashioned--
there we go.
Mathematica.
So you can see that this
arrangement, this disposition
of mine positions, which is
like over one, up two-- I've
got to zoom in a little bit.
Yeah, if you go over one,
up two, over one, up two,
this arrangement is going
to totally fill space.
So this is where I've colored
all the adjacent ones in.
And this is going to mean
that if you lay mines
at these centers, and you
have the pickaxe upgrade,
then you will be
fully tiling space.
Really useful.
And here I'm going to
give away the trick.
You'll be on the right spot
if mod of 2 plus your x val,
plus 1 times your
y val equals zero.
If mod, this number 5-- see
if I change this to like a 7,
then the whole pattern changes.
And you can investigate
different patterns
by playing around with it.
And these patterns may
have different effects,
depending on your upgrades and
the positioning of your mines.
And it made me get
kind of a neat idea.
So this is fully dense.
And you could do partly
dense, which is really simple.
You could just do mod i plus j,
where i and j are your x and y
values.
You just do mod 2.
And if that mod 2 is
equal to 1, then that'll
get you every other tile.
So no matter where
you are on the map,
you don't have to start
comparing to your allied tile
locations.
You don't have to start
doing a whole bunch of really
complicated operations.
Just say, if my robot
is on this nice tile,
then go ahead and lay a mine.
Really nice.
And here's an
interesting alternative.
So this one I slightly farther
spaced apart than the one
above.
This is sort of like knights in
chess, where they can move up
and up and up, or they can
move over and over and over.
Well here, I've gone and done
it a little bit farther apart.
And the result is this
neato looking structure.
So it's like the
one we did before,
where we had only done
a checkerboard pattern.
Only now, we have a
lot fewer mines to lay,
and we still get sort of
this interpenetrated mix.
This can be really useful
for fooling the enemy team.
The formula for this
system is 3x plus 1y.
And as long as you
mod that with 8,
you'll get the answer
you're looking for.
Now, this is sort of
an interesting system.
If I change this to 1,
and I change this to 5,
I get the same result
but sort of mirror image.
Just playing around with
this kind of problem
can be quite enlightening
if you're not
the kind of person who instantly
sees how these systems work.
So let's do some
summaries, and then
at the end of the
summaries, I'm going
to show you a really
awesome player.
A really amazing version
of this thing that
has the headquarters
telling it where to go.
So this is going to be at
the very end of lecture,
I'm going to show you.
It's the same as
this player that
just lost this match,
this one up here,
only instead of being dumb
when the enemy arrives,
it's going to be smart
about where it puts itself
with respect to the enemy.
Which is to say that
it's going to avoid
the enemy unless the
number of nearby allies
is a really high number.
And at the same time,
the central headquarters
is going to tell it
to capture encampments
and to build suppliers
and generators on them.
So you're going to start
to have a player that,
just from few little pieces,
is starting to do everything
it needs to do to
start winning matches.
So I'll show that
at the very end
after I summarize some
of things that I've done,
and some of the things that
I think you ought to try out.
Because I can put
this code together
in a certain amount
of time, but I
can't try every
possible combination.
So let's go straight
on over to here,
and I want to just talk
about two categories.
Let's talk about the shape
of your system, which
is to say the cloud.
Let's talk about how
you achieve the shape.
And you can achieve it
either using a headquarters,
and I'll talk about
all the amazing things
that you can have
the headquarter tell
the group that you might
not have thought of.
And you can achieve it
using this group mind.
So let's do the
group mind first,
where you could
check the neighbors
and go to the area
with the fewest.
I sent around some code.
I don't know how
many of you used it.
And it looked like this.
Let me show you my lecture
three robot player release.
It's not incredibly good code,
but you can see the point.
So when these guys get
close to one another,
each one has this list.
And this list shows the
number of adjacent enemy
and allied units.
So that list is
absolutely gosh darn tiny.
So I'm going to go ahead and
do a fancy way of zooming in.
Oh, my goodness.
That's even less legible.
That says 22, 21, 2,
0, 0, 1, 12, 23, me 12.
So me 12 means that I
have two allies adjacent
and one enemy adjacent.
And adjacent this number, these
are eight different numbers
indicating north,
northeast, east, southeast,
and so on, around
the clock directions.
Although not with
12, but with eight.
Yeah.
And it has this many enemies
and this many allies.
And so I've written the code
for you that will do this.
And so the robot
can sort of start
to make decisions about
who is adjacent to it.
All you've got to
do is start sorting
how good it is to be next
to allies or enemies.
Like maybe it's
really good to be
next to a lot of allies
and very few enemies.
Otherwise you want to
be close to few allies
so that you spread out.
There are a lot of things
that you can build on that.
So that's why I
included that code.
So you could check neighbors and
go to the area with the fewest.
You could compare to
neighbor repulsion.
So the repulsion is accomplished
in the following way.
So I've written this code
here in guided swarm.
And here's where you are
repelling from the enemies.
So it isn't just
one way of doing it.
A lot of ways of doing it.
But I've called this
function freeGo,
and it lets you
sort of freely float
among your various
alternatives of places to go.
What it does is it says,
all right, here I'm
starting at my location.
I'll get a direction
to the target location,
which is like the waypoint.
And now I'm going to
apply a target weight,
because maybe I really want
to get there if I'm far away.
But if I'm kind of close,
I don't really care.
So now I have this function
called target weight, where
if my distance squared
is greater than 100,
I'll call the weighting 5.
If my distance squared
is greater than 9,
I'll call the weighting 2.
And if I'm really close, then
I'll call the weighting 1.
So that's sort of giving me
this spring-like behavior
to get to where I want to go.
And it's going to give
me this gassy behavior.
So what I'll do is I'll
make a goal location, which
is not the same as the target.
So that goal location, I'm
going to just add to my location
this direction to the target.
So let's do it on Paint
to give an example.
Because saying words is not
always incredibly clear.
So here's me.
Here's my waypoint.
And maybe here is
the closest ally.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to repel from the ally,
and I'm going to
attract to the waypoint.
Which means I'm going to end
up having a bunch of guys that
are having competing
requirements.
Competing requirements
is like everything
in these kinds of
dynamic systems.
Because in the end,
you'll want to expect
them to find a balance between
these competing things.
Because frankly, they want to
do things that are inconsistent.
They want to be at
the waypoint, but they
don't want to be next
to their friends.
So that automatically means
that they can't be satisfied,
like a lot of people I know.
So you could see here
the repulsion term.
So if there are allies, then
it will locate the closest ally
using this function
that I wrote.
Very simple.
And then it will add to the
goal location negative 3
of the direction to
the closest ally.
so what the heck does that mean?
That's just saying repel.
So my goal location
started here.
And then I moved it toward
the waypoint some amount.
And it would be more
or less, depending
on where the waypoint
was with respect to me.
And now I'm going to take
the ally direction, which
is this direction, and I'm going
to subtract that from this.
So now I'm going
away from the ally
and toward the waypoint,
which gets me this x.
So in the final analysis,
this is my new goal location,
which is the sum of a bunch
of weighted added directions.
And now I'm going to
go that way, which
is going to get me both
toward the waypoint
and away from my ally.
I mean, on a grid,
this direction
may have been quite
close to or the same as
the direction directly
to the waypoint.
But when you keep
doing it over and over,
those little edge cases where
a small difference makes you
go one way or the other
start to become significant.
And so you can do it just
simply like this, where you only
care about where the
ally that's closest is.
And you only care
about the weighting
of where you're going.
But wait just a second.
There are so many things
you can add to it,
and that I did add when I
wrote my guided swarm two,
which is going to
end the lecture.
So let's do all the things
that you can repel or attract.
There's enemies.
And you repel or attract to them
based on how many there are.
There's mines .
And if they're
yours, do you want
to be right next to your mines?
Do you want to be behind them?
Do you want to be sort
of in a clump of them?
Do want to keep
laying mi-- I mean,
if you're in a
laying mines mode,
then you don't really
want to stand on a mine,
because then you can't lay one.
You're on one already.
So [INAUDIBLE] on
your current goals.
So you could imagine
making the following--
this would be so cool.
Somebody in this room
needs to do this.
I was going to do it for
today but ran out of time.
You do the following.
So here's what always
happens when I write players,
is I've got a center,
and people start
laying mines around the center.
I think you saw
this today, where
they were laying these mines.
And the mines reached
a certain amount,
and the robots were
only out to here.
And so that was it.
I didn't get any more mines.
But here's what you could do.
You could say, have
the headquarters,
which might be, say, down here.
Have it say, if-- let's do this.
Oh, my goodness.
Watch this.
Oh, uh, uh.
It's going to work.
Headquarters.
If there are a lot of mines
near the rally point-- and it
can do this very easily.
You know how to do it?
There's a really,
really handy function.
Don't do the following.
Here's years what you
were probably thinking.
What you might have done is
sense all the allied mines,
or whatever the function
name is, and then
parse through that list
and find the ones that
are close the waypoint.
You don't have to do that.
You don't have to
do that at all.
You can see here in the
documentation under Robot
Controller, there's a
method that really helps.
There's
senseMineLocations and it
will let you specify a
center, a radius, and a team.
So let's put that on here.
So you definitely
want to be using this
so that all you've got to
do is have the headquarters.
And why would you
use the headquarters?
Just so that it doesn't have
to be done again and again.
So the headquarters is going
say, how many mines are there
when this x is the center, and
I'm looking within some radius?
And you could just expand
the radius turn by turn
to see how many mines there
are until it starts to drop Off
or you could just like
set it at a given radius,
or the previous radius.
So yeah.
Let's do it that way.
And you would say, how many of
my mines are in this circle?
And so you'd say, if there
are full mines in the circle--
and you can do that pretty
easily because the circle is
defined by a radius
squared, right?
So expected mines is
like pi r squared, right?
That's a number of tiles.
But r squared we already
have, and pi as an integer
is equal to 3.
And so we can just say the
number of expected mines
equals 3 times the
radius squared.
And so that's also nice, because
it's a little bit less than pi.
And so if you're like mostly
filled of mines in that circle,
then-- so if the
detected mines is
greater than or equal to
expected mines in a full area,
then expand the mine radius.
And you might say, well, wait.
How am I expanding
the mine radius?
Well, here you go.
Here you go.
Right now, the function
looks like this
for the repulsion
and attraction.
It looks like the following.
Oh, I'm going to use this.
Yeah.
Like that.
So if this is the
distance x from center,
and this is the
repulsive force--
or I think we were attracting.
Yeah, we were attracting
to the center.
The attractive force
was greater the farther
you got from the center.
But you could imagine--
So that's going
to push everybody
toward the middle.
But you don't have to do that.
You could just as easily
have the headquarters--
the headquarters could
be telling everybody
by message systems
what this looks like.
And they could
very well tell them
to make it a little
bit more like this.
So let's say that you already
put mines out to this range.
So you've already put
mines here and you've
detected them using
the headquarters.
So now you want everybody
to show up here.
Well, you could
very simply do that.
All you've got to do is make
the forces look like this.
Oh, is that right?
No, we would want-- Yeah, yeah.
Well, that's the energy.
And the force is this.
The attractive force is this.
So this is exactly a spring.
That's a spring from physics.
And that will make them go
toward it if they are inside,
because they will go opposite
the direction of this vector
from the origin.
And they'll make
it go away if they
are in the other direction,
and you get the idea.
So that's a pretty
neat idea, because you
could have them
spread out in a circle
and maintain that sort
of positional authority,
as it were.
Very, very cool.
We are also going to talk
about some other awesome things
the headquarter
can tell them, even
though our mouths are watering.
Check the neighbors, OK.
We can avoid this.
We can avoid mines.
We can avoid the enemy.
We can do those things.
There's no more direction.
We've talked about that.
So now let's go
back a little bit
and talk about how
the headquarters can
help you achieve a given shape.
The headquarters can signal
when the enemy has artillery.
Now, how's the
headquarters going to know?
Well, it could
receive the message
from somebody else
that notices his hit
points have dropped by 20 or 40.
Or it could just
locate an artillery.
Like if you actually
physically walk past one,
then you could say there
is an artillery there.
I should start repelling
my other units.
They should start spreading
out, because if they are all
clumped together, they're going
to take a lot more damage.
They're going to take, instead
of 40 damage for just one hit,
they're going to take eight
splash damage as well.
And so that's going
to end up being
an additional five times worse.
Yeah.
Well, it's going to
be four times worse.
Five times as bad, as it were.
That's definitely no good.
So yeah, I mean,
that's how you're
changing the shape of your
cloud using the communication
that you're giving
from the headquarters
or from somewhere else.
So you could do that.
You can say, when
the group-- and you
could say like average
position-- has arrived
at a waypoint, like at a
waypoint that the headquarters
has specified, then
go to the next one.
And right there you can start
to fill the whole map that way.
Now, this is a
really crazy trick
that I think is the bee's knees.
And it's just going to make the
difference between amazing code
and non-amazing code.
So everybody is going to
have had this situation.
And I've had this
situation for a long time,
but I very rarely--
in fact, I've
never come up with a
solution until just recently.
And it was the following.
OK, so here's me.
Here's me and here's the goal.
OK I, want to go from
one to the other.
And a lot of times
what happens is
I've got a large
group of people,
and they end up splatting.
They just splat, and
then they trickle.
Like this is a little thin
line of trickled units.
And everybody else is
just splatting there,
and they're really unhappy.
Yeah, it's no good.
I think this guy here
has gone to sleep.
I mean, this guy
started to tunnel.
And so he's like
mining in there.
And then when these guys
arrived, he's like, I'm tired,
I'm going on a workers strike.
So I mean, it's just terrible.
So here's an
alternative to that that
may make the difference
between winning and losing.
This may just become
the dominant strategy.
I couldn't be more
infatuated with my idea.
And it works like this.
It works like this,
where I'd say, OK.
I'm headquarters.
I'm headquarters back here.
And I'm telling them what to do.
All I've got it do
is look here, here,
and here, and I can use
the senseNeutralMines.
I'll use the
senseNeutralMines, and I'll
put these as the centers.
One, two, three, four.
OK, five.
And these are the directions
that the whole swarm
could move.
And I'll say, OK, this has
seven mines and this has two.
No, this isn't realistic.
They all have zero.
OK, they all have zero.
Right?
But then once I move down a
little bit-- come on Paint,
come on Paint.
Help me out here.
OK.
Now I moved down a
little bit, and now
some directions really look bad.
So what I can do is
tell the whole swarm
to follow a waypoint set that
looks like a giant robot.
Not like a gundam, no.
Like one unit of robot.
So the whole swarm
becomes one big thing
that can all path
around the object,
because I've down
sampled the terrain.
This down sampling
idea can extend
to full search and
pathing algorithms.
So you'd split it up like this
or so, something like this.
They can be overlapping
or non-overlapping
down sample boxes.
You can use blur
or other features
as standard concepts
in computer science.
So that you can
start to do pathing
on a much simpler matrix.
And this can get you to
your enemy like leagues
faster than you
would otherwise get.
And if you use a heuristic,
then it doesn't even matter.
Let's say there's
like a few mines here.
Well, maybe you'll just
barrel right on through.
If you can just compare
to the amount of mines
that you're going to
find here versus here,
what better way to
make that comparison
than to count mines in
a giant area like this?
And these giant areas are going
to be so computationally simple
for you to compute, because
it's just one function call.
And I believe that function
call only costs you like $100.
And by dollars, I
mean byte codes.
So this has been a summary
of a bunch of types of swarm,
but it hasn't been a
complete summary yet, has it?
Because I told you I was going
to show you that amazing code
that I wrote.
And this time I may or may
not be being facetious.
And that amazing code where
I've made this guided swarm two,
and I'm going to play it
against a basic player on maybe
a couple of maps.
Basic player is not
horrible, I guess.
I don't really know
how good or bad
we are expecting to
claim that it is.
But let's go ahead
and show this match.
So here I've got
guided swarm in red.
And he's starting
out by building
a checkerboard pattern of mines.
And what he's going to do is
when he encounters the enemy,
he's sometimes going to just
rush straight at the enemy.
Other times he's going to
sort of back up and then only
fight at the right time.
In this example, it looks
like he was destroy-- oh.
Well, the enemy built artillery
right next to my base.
It doesn't count.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: OK, OK.
This one, here I am
down in the bottom left.
I'm going to get ready
to research pickaxe.
I'm going to do it.
And then when I
research pickaxe,
their mining pattern
is going to change.
They're going to
spread out, I think.
Or maybe-- I might not
have implemented it.
Well in any case, it's there.
It sort of exists in my mind
that I'll do that sometime.
So what I'll do is
when they arrive here,
I'll totally mess them up.
They're going to show up.
I'll back them up
just a little bit.
And then they're going
to be on my mines
and they're going to have
nothing to say about it.
They're going to just-- they're
going to-- oh, so there I go.
There I go.
I'm starting up to move out.
I'm starting to
continue to build mines.
And I'm going forward.
I don't know that-- I think he
doesn't have really any robots.
Yeah.
Yeah, super effective.
Oh my goodness.
That was fantastic.
I'm actually going
to do-- I wonder
if it is working
as I was expecting.
So in this one,
I'm going across.
And when the enemy shows,
what I'm hoping is-- oop.
It already ended.
Yes.
I'm hoping to sort of
back up just a little bit,
and then take them on.
No, it looks like I
just run straight in.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Well in any
case, I sort of spread out.
I made this neat little pattern.
I'm starting to take
these encampments.
It's getting done.
I'm doing it up.
Making it happen.
I take the other side.
I take more encampments.
And then I just sort of--
because these are like,
now I've got better
production than he has.
I'm going to cast
these games this well
when we have the finals.
It's going to be great.
I'm making more units.
Oh, look at this.
Do you see this like micro?
I'm backing up a little
bit, letting them do it.
I'm do some micro
here, making sure
that I outnumber the
enemy before I go in.
I'm not keeping it so
spread out as I was before.
Some guys are doing some
important philosophy.
[LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And those
philosophical results
just very well may
make the difference
between our salvation
as a species and not.
Thank you very much for
attending this swarm lecture.
Next lecture will
be about strategy.
And I hope you enjoy
the Indian food.